The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
How's everybody doing?
Good?
Yeah.
I wanted to start
with some inspiration.
And so because I love
videos, and I think
that's a way of inspiring.
And sometimes I think if
you feel really passionate
about something, you
can use song and video
as a way of
conveying your ideas.
I have a good friend, actually,
who's been doing that.
So I want to show you--
anybody heard of Fog and Smog?
OK.
Let's show you this little
video, just a minute of it.
DJ DAVE: What's crazy to
me is like nobody ever
talks in person anymore.
Like you got Twitter and
Facebook and everybody
sending text messages.
Like nobody's ever sitting down
like this and just talking.
You know?
For all these technologies,
we're actually further apart.
You know what I'm saying?
Hello?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That's
my good friend DJ Dave.
DJ DAVE: (RAPPING) Would you
please put your phone down?
You're not walking straight.
You're stumbling around.
You're in public, man.
You're being kinda
rude, and text messages
are not that important.
Excuse me, lady.
Could you please
put your phone down?
You're talking too loud,
like nobody's around.
I'm sure you'll find a way
to hear what you have to say.
I don't want to know
that much about your day.
I'm standing on line
at my favorite cafe,
trying to get my coffee,
like I do every single day.
This dude in front of me
is texting up a storm.
Thumbs moving like
bees in a damn swarm.
I mean, it's none of my business
how you spend your time,
but pay attention, dude.
You're like next in line.
He finally gets to the
counter and is like, um.
I'm like, man,
you're hella dumb.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: All right.
Anyway.
DJ DAVE: (RAPPING) Could you
you please put your phone down.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: All right.
So I won't show all the thing.
That's actually a good
family friend, DJ Dave.
I lived in his room for
a year, awesome guy,
and he's made some
really nice videos.
The point is-- this is not
quantum mechanics related--
it is a topic near and dear to
my heart as some of you know.
And I'm sure you're all
closing your laptops
and putting your phones down,
especially after seeing that.
But the point is,
he's passionate.
So what does he do?
He conveys his passion in song.
Now, if any of you--
so this is related to
the class-- if any of you
have an idea that
you're passionate about,
like say for your final
project, and you'd
like to do something
like that, I would really
be fully supportive.
I tried to-- some of you
may remember my attempts
to get you to do that in 3012,
and now guess how many people
actually did that in 3012?
Right, not so many.
But if somebody wants to
take a crack at conveying
their project in
this format, there's
got to be a bonus point
or two in that just alone.
Right?
Are any of you are
juniors, junior lab?
Are you doing that
in Van Vliet's class?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
did it last summer.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So I saw some of those, and
I'm like, man, I want that.
I think that's really
creative and cool.
So I see a lot of
really cool stuff.
I saw a couple of those.
They were really great.
So if anybody wants to do
that, let me know, and I'd
be happy to support
however I can,
put you in touch with Dave
if you want or whatever.
OK.
All right.
Any questions about
class products?
So I've been talking to some
of you about the projects,
and if anyone is still
interested, it's not too late.
But we're getting close
to being too late,
so please, come talk to me.
If you still want
to do a project,
this would be like the last week
I think to get something going.
What I want to do today
is-- well, before I start,
here's where we are.
OK?
So what I want to do is
continue on our march.
We talked about atoms
to solids, laid a little
of the groundwork.
We'll review some of that and
then go onto some of the things
you can do once
you model solids.
I want to do some
calculations, assuming
that it works, using the
nanoHUB interactively together.
Because again, there is nothing
like calculating the behavior
of electrons with friends.
There's no better way to
create a good group dynamics
and interactions.
Computing has the
nuts and bolts,
a lot of which we're talking
about, some of which were not,
and then it has sort
of the philosophy.
Right?
And I really tend to agree
with some of the things
that people have said over the
years on how to use computing.
And so I just want
to bring this in,
and I'll come back to this
at the end of the term
a little bit more.
But Richard Hamming had a number
of very interesting things
to say about research
and about computing.
The purpose of computing
is insight not numbers.
Right?
So the computation is only
as good as your creativity
and your thinking on both sides,
what you put into the computer
and what you get out.
He also said what are the
most important problems
in your field?
Are you working on one of them?
Why not?
I love that, and that's very
much an MIT ecosystem way,
but it's not true everywhere.
But we should always
remind ourselves,
even if I solve this problem--
so I'd say, my problem
is I want to change
the bandgap of silicon
from indirect to direct.
OK?
I can do that now,
because we've learned how
to do that using simulation.
So I can probe materials
using a computer.
You should still say, why?
The point isn't-- you
can't just say, why?
Well, because it
would be useful.
Or why, well, because it can
make a better solar cell.
That's not enough.
Right?
It's really how much
impact can you have?
What is this going to do to the
technology you're working on
or the science problem
you're trying to answer?
And taking it those extra
steps goes a long way,
and that applies
to computing, just
like any other area of research.
Better to solve the right
problem the wrong way
than the wrong
problem the right way.
So choosing the problem
that's a related statement.
In research, if you
know what you're doing,
then you shouldn't be doing it.
I like that a lot,
and that's where
computation is a real enabler.
I love experiments too, but I
love the world of computation,
especially at this scale.
Where you can design--
within a limited
number of atoms--
you can design anything.
You can think up
anything and try it.
Right?
So there's really the phase
space is just enormous,
and you can really
play around and try
crazy ideas, random thoughts,
and tangents out as you go.
Those are often where the
best creativity happens.
And then this is it.
Right?
Machines should work.
People should think.
So as you go after this
class, and you come out,
one of the most important
things to come out of this
is it's always a balance.
When you do computation,
it's a balance
between your time and
the computer's time.
And what you'd like
to do is create
a balance, such
that the computer is
solving things for you.
And you're spending most of your
time not solving those things,
not wasting your time on things
that the computer could do,
but rather on thinking
about the kind of problem
that you're going to make it do.
And you'd be surprised how often
in computation this balance
is not well kept.
OK?
And how often you might
spend a lot of your time
actually spinning your
wheels on something
that the machine
could actually handle.
Right?
And how much you might
think the machine
is actually going
to somehow solve
a problem that actually you
need to think about to solve.
Or how much more quickly you
could solve it, if you just
thought for an hour.
You might have saved a million
hours of computer time.
Right?
Seriously, so that balance
always has to be kept in mind.
And then the one I like to
add is Spider Man's uncle,
with great power comes
great responsibility,
because you have now power.
You're gaining power.
That's what this
class is doing to you.
You're gaining the power
to calculate things
like band structures.
Right?
And the responsibility
is that I want
you to know what you're doing.
In the sense that
you don't just say
I'm going to do
a bang structure.
Oh, here it is.
You check, and you're
careful about it.
Right?
And you understand how to
validate the calculations
that you're doing
against experiment,
and you understand how to
converge the calculations.
You understand how to make sure
you understand what they mean.
That's the responsibility.
OK?
So a little bit of
philosophy there.
Anyway, OK.
We're going to
review a little bit,
and we'll talk about
some properties.
We'll come back to
this band structure
which is so critical to
this part of the class.
And if I have time, I'll
talk about magnetization,
but probably, I'll talk
about magnetization
on Thursday a little.
All right?
Any questions?
So we've had a rap
video, some philosophy,
a little bit of an outline.
Where else can we go?
Right?
Things are good.
Rondo, what's up with that?
Was that a good decision?
No?
How many people saw that?
I just want to know.
OK, so a little
more people are--
But you only saw
it on a highlight.
Oh, you watched the game.
All right.
Good.
Yeah.
But they're going to win
without Rondo tonight.
Anyway, OK.
Yeah.
You bump a ref on purpose?
Come on.
Come on, man.
Anyway, I can't spend
more time on it.
I don't want to do that.
Let's take a walk through
memory lane for just a moment,
because I want to make sure
we all know where we are.
Right?
We started with this.
There were some
strange observations
by some very smart people.
Tell me what those are.
We could ask questions like
about these on the quiz.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Those are electrons.
Yeah.
That's an electron.
Those are electrons.
What's this experiment?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
This one is?
What's this one?
AUDIENCE: Collapsing
if that happens.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Why does it collapse?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] classical.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Classical,
then it's got to be what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It's giving off
energy, and it's not
going to hang into its orbit.
But then quantum
mechanics came along
and said, no, that's not true.
Right?
Because what?
It just is.
It's the 'It just is" answer.
No, because what it
said is that the levels
of a quantum mechanical
object are quantized,
and they have to
be in those places.
And there's no in between,
and that's what this is.
What's this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Which comes
from that same observation.
You'd think that the
universe, the hydrogen
might emit colors in any
frequency, but instead only
certain frequencies.
And it comes from that
quantization of those electron
levels, and this, somebody
already said this.
Right?
Photoelectric effect.
OK?
Now, those are
very smart people,
and the weirdness kept going.
Now, is that guy ordering
two drinks at the bar?
Why does he have two?
Double slit experiment, that was
a cool one, and the weirdness
just kept going.
Right?
Now, it became very clear that
matter behaved like waves.
If we took this little
10-slide, where we are,
quick, what road if we
come on, and we turned it
into a music video.
Right?
Anybody want to do that?
That's exciting.
OK.
It became clear that matter
behave like waves and vice
versa.
OK?
And that we had to lose
our classical concepts
of absolute position
of momentum and instead
consider a particle as a wave
whose square is the probability
of finding it, and there it is.
And this became our goal,
our task of finding that.
Right?
That's what we needed
to do on a computer,
and there's a picture of a wave.
How do we do this?
How do we describe this?
Well, we needed our F equals ma.
Right?
So when matter is just a
particle, we have F equals ma,
but now that it's a wave, we
needed something different.
And from the
elements and the bits
of pieces of quantum
mechanics, which
people were putting
together, out comes
the Schrodinger equation.
And that's our F equals
ma, which tells us
how to describe the
behavior of waves,
if they're quantum mechanical,
and it was wonderful.
It explained many things.
It gave us atomic orbitals.
It predicted the energy
levels of hydrogen.
Remember how wonderful that was?
It gave us, basically,
the means to understand
a whole lot of this.
Right?
But nature does more
than one electron,
and it was impossible
to solve for more
than a single electron.
So here's where computational
quantum mechanics comes in.
OK?
But there was still a
problem, and the problem
is that we don't have
the age of the universe
to do our calculations.
And so that's how long it
would take to currently solve
the Schrodinger equation
exactly on a computer
for like only a
handful of particles.
Right?
Obviously, you could
solve it for one
or two particles exactly in
a lot less time than that,
but once you get up
to 10, you're done.
And so we started to try
to take some inspiration,
and we looked at
this, a guy's back.
And we said, OK, well, maybe
that's telling us something.
It's telling us a lot,
but it's telling us
some interesting physics.
It's telling us that the
ions are a whole lot heavier
and slower than the electrons.
So we can freeze them out.
So we started to peel away
at the Schrodinger equation,
and we made it simpler.
OK?
We made some approximations,
and there are basically
the two paths that I talked
about in those approximations.
At the time, it's about
50 years ago, maybe 60,
these two paths were
fairly distinct.
And the chemists mostly
worked on saying, well, here's
the equation we have to solve.
We can't solve it.
Let's make psi
something simpler.
Let's simplify psi.
And the physicists
mostly said, well,
let's not think about psi.
Let's just change
the Hamiltonian.
That's h there.
Right?
And those are two
approaches that
led to many different models,
many different theories,
many different theories.
In the theories, in
both sides, the effect
of these simplifications
led to the picture
that we call a
mean field picture.
Which is that instead of
having to worry about all
these quantum mechanical
electrons interacting
with each other, we
just worry about them
as if it's each one is in
the field of the others,
an average field of
the others, and that's
called the mean field method.
OK?
Those are the methods
we're using in this class.
That's the method we're using.
And then we talked about
density functional theory,
and the breakthrough
there is that trying
to keep track of a
wave function, let's
say, on a grid of a 2 by 2
grid or 3 by 3 or whatever.
Well, this is for actually
a 2 by 2 by 2 grid,
and you have N electrons.
Well, if you have N
is 1, so 1 electron,
you have 8 points you
need to keep track of.
But if you had
just 10 electrons,
then you see that you
get 10 to the 9th points.
OK?
This is the problem of using
grids to represent things.
And so if you use the density
instead, it's just a constant.
Tracking the density
is much easier,
and the crux of density
functional theory,
which was worked out in the
'60s, is that there is a 1 to 1
correspondence between the
exact density of the system
and the wave function.
OK?
And we talked about
this last time,
about how we sit
here, because it's
a nice compromise between
accuracy and applicability.
But I want to come back to
this, because this is not--
part of the reason I wanted to
remind you of this is that it's
just always fun to take these
walks through memory lane,
and it only took
us five minutes.
But another reason
is that I want
to remind you that we are not
solving for quantum mechanics
exactly.
We're not.
We cannot.
OK?
This is what I mean by
the responsibility part.
OK?
There are some things
that DFT can give you,
can calculate about those
electrons, that are typically
very accurate, but
there are some things
where it's actually quite off.
It's an approximation.
Does anybody remember
where it tends to do well?
I did talk about this in
the third or fourth lecture
and where it tends to do badly.
Yeah.
Or one of those two.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
solids, periodic structures.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
What about the solids,
what properties?
AUDIENCE: Bandgaps.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
That would be
a case where it falls into
the not so well category.
OK?
So this is pretty important.
AUDIENCE: Lattice parameters?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Lattice parameters, yes.
It tends to do very well
for lattice parameters.
So how far apart
should atoms be,
if they come together in a
molecule or solid or a liquid?
DFT can do very well.
It does very well for
vibrational properties,
vibrational spectrum, the
phonons in a material.
It tends to do worse
for excited states,
like looking at,
say, the optical gap
or the electronic
gap of material.
It tends to the
approximations that we
had to use to get a method
that's workable, all of these
have approximations,
except this.
See?
We're up to two electrons here.
Those approximations lead to DFT
not doing so well for the gap.
However, as you may have noticed
in your homeworks, that's
one of the things
you have to calculate
in your second homework.
So here's the point
I want to make.
These methods have
advantages and disadvantages.
They all are approximate.
Some quantum mechanical methods
can describe some things
very accurately and some
things not as accurately,
and others may have
different balances.
And as you go down to
more accurate methods that
can describe more
things very accurately,
you tend to be able to do less
and less numbers of electrons.
Right?
Limit your phase space
to 12, 20 electrons,
and you're pretty limited in how
many materials you can explore.
Right?
Now, why can we still
calculate the gap?
Well, and this is,
actually, there's
going to be an addendum
to your homework
which I'm going to have to--
I forgot to put this
in there, but if this
is the density of states.
OK.
Let's say that's the
density of states.
By the way, if I
asked you what's
the gap of this material,
what would you say?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Those are between
the first density of states
and second density of states.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well,
that would be true but I need
to know one thing very
importantly or I cannot answer
whether that's the case.
What do I need to know?
I need to know the
position of something here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: The
Fermi energy, who said that?
Very good.
Fermi energy, came
from over there.
OK?
Now, if I tell you that
the Fermi energy is here.
Then, you're absolutely right.
It's the difference--
and in the DOS plots
you get on the nanoHUB,
these are essentially
levels that come out.
If it's a molecule, they're
levels that come out,
and then they're spread
out a little bit.
So it's very likely this
peak height versus that
is going to give you the gap.
And in the nanoHUB
tool, the Fermi energy
is always set to 0 for you.
OK?
But if I don't specify
it, you may not know.
Now, is that a semiconductor
or an insulator?
Is it a metal?
Semiconductor?
How do you know?
You have a feeling?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
between the two bands.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: OK.
Well, let's say I put it here.
Semiconductor?
Insulator?
Wait, why can I not
answer that question?
What don't you know?
AUDIENCE: You don't
know the scale.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: What if
I told you that this was 0.1,
and this was 0.2, and the scale
is in eV, then what is it?
It's a 0.1 eV gap semiconductor.
Right?
OK?
So well, that's
like almost a metal,
but it's still semiconductor.
It's a very low
bandgap semiconductor,
where actually
electrons will probably
populate the conduction
band just thermally
to an interesting probability.
Now, if I told you this was
10 eV, what would it be?
AUDIENCE: Insulator?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Insulator.
OK?
Now, I'm going to go on.
Don't worry, but the
last point is DFT,
I'm not going to go
into the details of why,
but DFT tends to
underestimate the bandgap.
OK?
And so there are now
sophisticated ways
of correcting that and going
beyond DFT that we're not going
to talk about in this class.
But what we are
going to do is we're
going to use an
approximation that
was used for 20 years in
the scientific literature
and community to correct
for this problem.
And that is simply
called a scissor shift,
where basically, you see,
DFT gets the bandgap wrong,
but it gets qualitatively
very often the picture right.
It just gets the
bandgap too small.
So very often, we just shift
the conduction band states
by some correction.
OK?
I will give you that correction.
That will be the
addendum in the homework,
because you'll need that.
So the DOS plots
that you calculate
for these solar fuels, think
of them as pretty good,
except you have to
shift these states up.
So qualitatively, these
states are not bad,
but they're just
too low in energy
compared to the occupied states.
OK?
So that's a method that is not
really used very often anymore,
but it was used heavily
in the '70s and '80s,
to use DFT to look at
DOS and band structures.
Nowadays, we do
have methods that
go further that allow
us to actually calculate
these things without some
rigid shift approximation,
but calculate them more
from first principles.
I won't go into
those in this class.
OK?
Any questions?
So you'll have to
download your DOS plot
and do the shift that
I give you to the data.
All right?
Seems like a cheat, and
it actually is a cheat.
But like I said the qualitative
nature of these states
is still very good often.
OK?
So that's a property DFT
does not do so well on.
OK.
I won't go through the
self-consistent cycle.
What we did on Tuesday is
we talked about solids.
OK?
So we talked about
the periodic cell,
and we talked about
crystal symmetries.
And this was all review,
I think, for most of you,
and most symmetries are--
most common lattices are cubic
or hexagonal, close back.
Anybody know why?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Lower energy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Because of what?
AUDIENCE: More atoms.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
You pack them in.
Makes sense.
OK?
And then, and this
is sort of where
we spent some time
Tuesday and I want
to make sure we feel our
oneness with this k-space thing.
So associated with each
real space lattice,
there exists something we
call reciprocal lattice.
It's a set of wave
vectors which are
commensurate with the
real space lattice.
Sometimes, we call
it G. Why not?
Those are the lattice
vectors in reciprocal space.
And we define them as
a star, b star, c star.
That's a lattice in real
space, BCC, BCC lattice.
And there's the
reciprocal space lattice.
It's a real lattice.
It has distances
in lattice world,
in reciprocal lattice world.
It just looks different.
And actually, the
inverse of BCC is FCC.
So we talked about all this.
And then we talked
about how you can define
a zone within reciprocal space.
And the first-- if you take--
if you draw lines between
neighbors and nearest neighbors
and you draw bisections,
then you define that zone.
And that's called
the Brillouin zone.
And so you see here in this
square lattice, it's a square.
In here, it's going
to be a hexagon.
And if we define that
zone in three dimensions--
well, here, it's squares
and hexagons on the edges.
But it's a volume.
Does everybody-- so we're
just defining space, still.
And then came the
Bloch's theorem.
And in Bloch's
theorem, what we said
is that values of a
function, like the density,
should be the same
because it's a crystal.
But the wave function
is periodic only when
multiplied by a phase factor.
And that's-- I didn't
go into a lot of detail.
But that's Bloch's theorem.
So it says that the
wave function picks up
a phase factor, which depends
on this new quantum number.
That's all review
from last week.
And you can see that if the
wave function looks like that--
so if you add--
the periodicity
of the lattice is
big R. R is just
anywhere in real space.
Then you're going to
get this phase factor.
And if you square them,
say, to get the density,
then you can show that the
densities are the same.
Also, and this is
important, the wave function
picks up a phase if you
just go by the periodicity
of the real space lattice.
But if I increase k, if I add
an inverse lattice vector to k,
then they're exactly the same.
So in k-space, I can
also translate around.
And the energies are the same.
We're going somewhere here.
We're going somewhere.
Give me a minute.
And then I showed you this.
And does anybody have
questions about this?
The parallel here, I think,
is pretty self-explanatory.
In the hydrogen atom, we
impose this spherical symmetry.
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZING]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Gesundheit.
And we got out of that
quantization-- we solved.
And here, we impose a
translational symmetry.
And we get out of
that k-vectorization.
We-- but k is not a--
k is a quantum number.
But it can be continuous.
It can be continuous.
And you look at it in
the first Brillouin zone.
Now, somebody tell me,
given this, why would
I worry about k only--
AUDIENCE: Sorry
to interrupt you.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: No problem.
AUDIENCE: I'm just videotaping.
And we're just hearing
the mic move a lot.
I'm just going to--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: There you go.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
So I should stop--
I kind of-- no.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That rap
got me a little bit excited.
So let's go back to slide 1.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: So I'm
adding an inverse lattice
vector, a full vector, that
gets me to another lattice
point in inverse space.
And I say my wave
function is the same.
Now, why is it--
I also defined a Brillouin zone.
And you can see my definition
of the Brillouin zone
is, in fact, that
it's a zone that--
it's a lattice vector.
You see, those are
the lattice vectors.
Why is it that I only now
care about the variation of k
within that first
Brillouin zone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Same thing.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: The same.
That's why we care so much
about that Brillouin zone.
What is it?
Well, it's the boundaries
of the variability
of the wave function in
terms of how it depends on k.
So I only need to vary
k in this first zone.
But I do need to
vary it in that zone.
I have to vary it in that zone
because there will be variation
if it's a solid.
But if I vary it and then go
out here, well, it's just--
I can translate it back.
And it's the same
thing, you see?
So I need to move k
around in this first zone.
And when I do, and this is
a slide I've showed before--
when I do, what
you get is, as you
go-- as you think about a system
going from atoms to molecules
to bands in your
solid, you see this
is the energy of that band.
It wiggles.
That's what happens
in that first zone.
You have a new quantum number.
You change it.
And you vary the energy.
It wiggles.
So now these
orbitals are wiggly.
And that's the big--
the most important thing.
And you can see here--
so here's my k-space.
And I can vary kx, ky, kz if
it's three-dimensional solid.
And at each point
in k-space, you
are going to get
a set of levels,
just like you did for
that atom or molecule.
You're going to get
a set of levels.
And they will vary.
But they will be the
same if I translate
by the inverse lattice vector.
So if I go from here
out some G vector,
then I get exactly
the same levels.
But if I'm inside this Brillouin
zone, they're going to vary.
Any questions?
K-space is really
important for solids.
Mm-hmm.
And so what do we do?
Well-- so the inverse lattice--
it's related to the
real space lattice.
If I double the real space
lattice so it's periodic,
but with more
atoms in the cell--
so it's periodic over
a larger domain--
then, basically, I'm--
it's like a Fourier series.
So if I go to larger
real space lattice, then
I have finer and finer k-space.
And so what that
means is that you
can choose a certain k-mesh.
This is a variable in
the input now for solids.
For solids, this is a
new critical variable
in your calculations of solids.
You need a k-mesh.
And this is just a number.
You'll enter 8 or 2 or 4.
And it'll just do a cube
because it's simple.
But you don't have to do a cube.
But the code does a
cube on the nanoHUB.
So if I enter 8 by 8 by 8, I
get 512 k-points on a mesh.
And what that does
is it allows me to--
it is-- it, effectively, is like
increasing how much real space
I had because they're related.
If I had a larger unit
cell with more real space,
I'd have finer
and finer k-space.
And so you can think
about these things
as being able to
go back and forth.
Now, the reason that you
don't go to-- and now, well,
how many k-points do you need?
Well, you need to
have enough k-points--
you need to distribute k-points
in your Brillouin zone such
that--
what?
What's the answer?
How many k-points do I need?
It's my favorite answer.
AUDIENCE: It depends.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It depends.
What does it depend on?
Did that come from the back?
I love it.
What does it depend on?
AUDIENCE: The
electrons [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It might
depend on the electrons.
What else might it depend on?
How many k-points do I need?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yes.
Yes.
Look at this picture.
Let's look back at this picture.
Think about this.
And now try to think about
how many k-points do I need.
AUDIENCE: Enough [INAUDIBLE].
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Exactly.
I need enough.
Now, what's enough?
Well, enough so that
you can resolve how
the energy is going to change.
So now tell me, if the wiggles
are slow and not so much,
if the wiggles are like this, or
maybe even they're really flat,
do I need a lot of k-points
or a little bit of k-points?
How many?
A lot?
Just a little bit
because there's just
not that much variation.
But if the wiggles
looked like this,
would I need a lot or a little?
And so this is the
behavior of bands
that look like this-- are
more sort of metallicy.
And the behavior of bands that
look like this, the flat ones,
are more "insulatorey."
And in between-- and
we'll see-- on Thursday,
we'll talk about how you can
actually calculate the mobility
from these bands from this
Wiggle.
But you can-- how
many do you need?
Well, it depends.
It depends on the
nature of the material.
But you have to converge that.
That's part of that
responsibility.
Spiderman's uncle
knew all about it.
And so this is where we ended.
Oh, man.
Come on.
There we go.
This is where we ended.
And so you have energy
levels in the Brillouin zone.
k is a continuous variable.
But you don't actually
continue it everywhere
because it's too hard.
So you just do--
what the computer
does is a bunch of calculations
at different k-points
on the grid you give it.
And what you're
doing then is you're
moving through-- when you
give it different k-points,
literally, this is what you do.
You say, compute the--
what the computer is
doing is it's saying,
compute the energy levels
at k-point 0, 0, 0.
Now compute the energy levels
at k-points point 1, point 1,
point 1.
And you literally just give
it coordinates of k-points
within the Brillouin zone.
And for each of those k-points,
it does the calculations.
And it finds a set of energy
levels, which are different.
And those-- and then
you fill that in.
And you get your curvy bands.
Who's with me?
Who's got questions?
Anyone have questions?
That's the new-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: So at each
point, is a distinct number
of energy states
within the electrons?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Well, each k-point is the
same number of energy states.
But they can move around
depending on where
you are in that Brillouin zone.
And their "moving-aroundness"
is what gives you the band
structure.
So in the code, and I did
this on the previous slide--
I didn't talk about it.
It was the second point.
But on the code, you--
each one of these you
can think of as
occupied by electrons
because it's looking at this
k-point and then this k-point.
But when you think
about the full band
structure of a material, that
is not how you look at it.
You don't have-- you would--
as you keep increasing
your k-point mesh,
you would have infinite
number of electrons in a band.
That is not the case.
What you have is
the same as before,
the same exact thing
as molecular states,
which is that you
can have-- one band
can hold two electrons--
one up, one down.
That's exactly the same
as in a molecular state.
But depending on where you
are in the Brillouin zone,
the energy of that band now
can change dramatically.
And that changes
everything in terms
of properties of material.
In particular, what
we're focusing on here
is optical properties
and electronic properties
because those are very quantum
mechanically, which we like.
Now-- and the Fermi
energy is in the code--
we talked about the Fermi energy
a little bit for molecules.
It's sort of the energy
at which you stop filling.
It's the energy-- so
you fill your bands up
to the Fermi energy.
You can just think
about it that way.
Don't worry about-- so much
about whether it's in the gap
or where it is in the gap.
We don't need to worry
about that in this class.
But it is the energy at where--
at which you stop filling.
And so you can see that if you--
I have some properties.
I thought I had somebody else.
But if you were to fill
these and the bands--
and these bands didn't
stop nicely, like this,
but they just crossed over
it, what would you have?
What kind of material
would you have?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It's a metal.
And if you have the bands
stop where you stop filling
and then there's a gap, it's a
semiconductor or an insulator.
Let's do a few calculations.
And then I'll come back
to structural properties.
We are on our favorite
place, the HUB of nano.
Come on.
Yes!
We got to that stage.
Launch Tool-- it sounds
like a good idea.
And this is where we had
some issues last time--
not going to kid you.
There it is.
And we go to here.
Now, let's do a few things.
And so this is the same as--
so it's not letting
me scroll again.
That's wonderful.
There it is.
Now, this is the
same as the tool
that you're using for
the homework number 2
to look at molecules.
And in looking at molecules,
you just select Molecule.
But all the code is doing
when you look at molecules--
all the code is
doing is it's saying,
well, whatever you give
me, whatever sort of thing
you give me, I'm going to put
space in my periodic cell.
I'm going to put
enough space so that it
doesn't see its own image.
That's all it's doing.
It's still a
periodic calculation.
It's just putting a whole
bunch of space in there.
You could choose Solid and
do molecule calculations
and just make sure that there's
space between what you put in.
However, when you
choose Solid, then you
can see that it's actually
entering the coordinates
in a different way.
It's using a slightly
different language.
Has anybody seen this
beautiful non-scrolling thing?
Man.
Oh, yeah.
Well, it's good
to be challenged.
That's fun.
So-- you gotta be kidding me.
Did you see that coming?
Did somebody see that coming?
Should we go back to the--
to DJ Dave?
Wait.
What if I did Firefox?
Is that better?
It's the same.
That's beautiful.
You get the same thing?
It did remember me.
Now let's close that.
How often does that happen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: But what
percentage, would you say?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: 60% of the time.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
60% of the time?
60--
AUDIENCE: I feel the nanoHub
[INAUDIBLE] are generally not
stable for the Macintosh
machines and for the Unix--
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Oh, no, no, no.
You can't be blaming
this on a Mac.
This is-- because
it's not a Mac.
AUDIENCE: Not a Macintosh.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I mean the software.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
That must be.
AUDIENCE: I think the software
is unfriendly for Windows.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Well,
that's a big problem.
So here we are.
This looks a little bit better.
Now, when you choose Solid--
so now we have-- look at this.
[GASPING]
You can choose your crystal
symmetry because it's a solid.
And remember those
symmetries that you saw?
Well, these are those
symmetries except now
you have to choose
a lattice constant.
See, when you did the
molecule, the lattice constant
was simply big.
It was just big so
that the molecule
didn't fill its periodic image.
But now that we're
doing a solid,
the lattice constant
has to be, well,
like the lattice
constant of the material.
And depending on the
symmetry of the material,
you're going to get
different lattice constants.
So if I-- now--
and have any of you
seen fractional
coordinates before?
Does anybody know what this is?
So this is actually an important
language of solids where,
oftentimes--
so with a solid, you have a
periodically repeating space
that is set by a
lattice constant.
And so often, it's simpler to
think about the coordinates
that go inside that space--
the basis, if you want--
as fractions of the lattice.
So for silicon, actually--
for silicon, it's an
FCC crystal with a basis
at one corner of the
FCC and another atom
at a quarter-quarter-quarter
out in terms of the lattice.
This is not at a
quarter-quarter-quarter
angstroms.
This is a
quarter-quarter-quarter scaled
by that lattice--
does everybody see that--
which is a cubic
face-centered lattice.
So that's fractional
coordinates.
You can go back and forth.
You can write a 10-line Python
script to go back and forth
between the two.
But in solids, often we like to
think about positions in terms
of the symmetry of the lattice.
And so that's how we write them.
Now, in this case, I
have two silicon atoms.
And we're going to ignore
everything and just run it.
Is that how you guys do it,
anyway, you just simulate?
It's fun to do
that, just simulate,
except that you need
to know what you did.
Now, that's what I want to ask
you about-- is what did I do?
Oh, look at that.
This is solid.
I only gave it two atoms.
And yet, because
it has the symmetry
in the lattice and all that, it
knows how to construct a solid.
And that's what it looks like.
When the computer
thinks about it,
it thinks about it like that.
Uh-oh.
Where's the-- oh, here we go.
Now, key outputs-- it's telling
you that it has-- well, these
should really be 4.
It has four up electrons
and four down electrons.
That doesn't sound like
that many electrons.
How come I only have eight
electrons in my simulation
and I'm simulating
an infinite crystal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So very good.
But how come-- so
it's only the valence
because that's where all
the chemistry happens.
We talked about that.
But why are the only two atoms?
How can I simulate a
solid with only two atoms?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Because
it's symmetric.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Because it's symmetric.
However, because I only
have two atoms, especially,
and it's symmetric
and it repeats,
I need to worry about the
convergence of what, which
we just talked about?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: And
so you saw-- the density
of states we talked about.
Oh, this is beautiful.
Look at this.
It's beautiful.
Those are the peaks of the
solid of crystalline silicon.
It's just like in the molecules.
In the molecules,
we had the levels.
And we turned them
on their side.
We turned the levels
And we said that's
the same as the DoS.
But in the solid, it's the band
structure we turn on its side.
Here's the band structure.
So those are my levels now.
Those are my levels.
They're wiggly in
reciprocal space.
But if I turn--
I can still turn
them on their side.
And when I do that, I get
the density of states,
directly comparable to the
situation of the molecules.
But in the molecules,
what I turned on its side
didn't wiggle.
Does everybody see that?
So there's the band structure.
Now, this is-- the nanoHUB
has issues with putting
Greek letters on plots.
So this is the band structure
with the Greek letters.
And I'll talk about-- well,
actually, I don't need to wait.
These just correspond
to different points
in that Brillouin zone.
You cruise through phase
space in the Brillouin zone.
And you plot the energies--
the code is plotting the
energies along that path.
So you get a sense
of the variation.
Could these energies
vary differently
than I've plotted here?
Could they vary differently?
How could they vary differently?
The answer is yes.
This is a cruise
through phase space.
Gamma is always the origin.
Gamma's at k-point 0, 0, 0.
And then I went to
some other k-point.
And we called it
X. We like to give
high-symmetry points
in the Brillouin zone
a letter, a Greek
letter, or not.
And then I went back to gamma.
Here, I went to a point
we called L. And I--
the way you do this is
you just, basically,
go in a line from this
point to that point.
And you plot the change
in the energy of each band
as you go from point to
point in the Brillouin zone.
So now, tell me, are
those the only variations
that you could have?
Why not?
Tell me why not.
AUDIENCE: If you choose a
different path, [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: If you
choose a different path.
This is just one path going
from L to gamma to X. You see,
here we are.
I went-- you see,
here they are for FCC,
I think, or maybe it's BCC.
I went from gamma to
L to X. I went just
along a line in
this Brillouin zone.
But what if I had gone like this
or what if I'd done like this?
Would I get
different curvatures?
You better believe it.
You are taking paths
through the Brillouin zone
to get the band structure.
That's how you get
the band structure.
Now, what ends up happening is
that the interesting variations
in these energy bands,
the interesting ones,
the ones that are important
for optical and electronic
properties, tend to happen
between the high-symmetry
points in the Brillouin zone.
They tend to happen between
the origin and the center
of this face and the
center of this edge
and going back to an origin.
They tend to happen between the
path of one high-symmetry point
to another.
And so, de facto,
we just don't care
much about everything
else in the Brillouin zone
because it doesn't really
give us extra information.
It would give us a
different band structure.
But it's not that--
it's not giving us
something that's
as relevant to the key
fundamental properties
we care about.
So that's one thing.
Now-- so that's where those--
now, the code just
picks the paths.
But in all these codes, you can
enter whatever path you want.
So if you want to
cruise around in k-space
and get energy
variations, you can do it.
You are not limited.
Now, is this the right
band structure for silicon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Let's go back to our--
not bad-- looks pretty good.
I like that.
That's why I want to-- now,
if we go back to the input,
what is it that--
of these parameters, what is
it that I might need to check?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What is that?
Say that again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
So I might--
I have a 4-by-4 grid.
Would I get a-- would I get
curvy band structures if I do
a 1-by-1-by-1?
Let's see.
Let's try it.
I'll do 14.
This seems to be stable for now.
Uh-oh, where's my
Simulate button?
There it is.
So I'm doing a
1-by-1-by-1 k-point.
This is another
key concept I want
to make sure we understand.
There it is.
There's silicon.
I didn't change anything
about the real space.
about the k-space.
I just only evaluated
the density at one point.
Now, here's what's going
to perhaps surprise
you, which is that the band
structure still curves.
Now-- and it curves
differently, actually,
than it did when
I had 4-by-4-by-4.
Why would it still curve?
This is actually something
I didn't talk about yet.
But it is an aside that I
was going to talk about.
But since I have it here,
I'll just talk about it now.
I probably could have
done all that internally
without voicing it.
But here we are.
So you see, when you
calculate the band structure,
what you do is
you do two things.
First, you converge the
wave function in density.
density at the k-points I input
into the input.
So if I have a 1-by-1-by-1
k-point density, well,
that gives me some grid.
That gives me some density
and some wave function.
Now, then to calculate the band
structure, what the code does
is it does a second step.
It takes that converged density.
And it cruises
around in k-space.
And that's how it
plots this out.
But it doesn't change
the density anymore.
It doesn't change the
converged wave function.
It just evaluates
it at all kinds
of different points in k-space.
So there's two steps.
First, you converge the density
at some number of k-points.
Then you cruise around
in the Brillouin zone
with that density.
And you evaluate your functions.
And sure, the wrong
density will still
wiggle as you move
around in k-space.
It'll still wiggle.
But it's the wrong
density because I
didn't have enough k-points in
the first place to converge it.
Does everybody see that?
So now, how many
k-points do I need?
Well, the number
of k-points I need
is when this converges
and doesn't change anymore
if the band structure--
if properties of the band
structure are what I want.
That's how many k-points I need.
Does everybody see that?
That's the difference.
Now-- no.
That wasn't good.
Here we go.
Oh, yeah.
These so-called web browsers--
Marc Andreessen was my
student, by the way, that--
does anybody know who he is?
No one knows who he is.
I'm dated.
No.
He was at Illinois,
where I did my PhD.
And I was his TA.
And he went and
founded Netscape--
good guy.
That's not one of my
browser options anymore.
So what's up with that?
Now, what I want to do
now is the following.
I'm going to go to one atom.
And what I want to know is--
and you can do that.
Just like before,
you can mess around.
One atom-- we'll just
leave it at one k-point.
And what I want to know is, am
I going to get a band structure
with one atom in the unit cell?
Oh, there it is.
They're kind of far apart.
What do you guys think?
That's one atom in the
corner of an FCC cell.
Will I get a band structure?
Just say yes or no.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
There it is.
Now, why is it curving?
Let me ask it a different way.
How could I get these
bands to stop curving?
Just stop curving already!
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
What is that?
AUDIENCE: Larger k-mesh space?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Larger
k-mesh space or other space?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] space.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Why
are they curving again?
Why are these things curving?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
It has to do with that.
But why do you get-- we talked
a lot in the last half-hour
about how you get this variation
in k-space of the band.
Why do you get that, again?
Why do you get that?
You get it because
of Bloch's theorem.
I'll tell you that.
But why does that matter?
AUDIENCE: It's periodic.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
It's periodic.
You got a periodic potential.
And so if it's--
so when would you expect the
curviness to stop curving?
Well-- or if you don't really
have a crystal anymore.
This looks a little less curvy.
What if I actually
made the spacing--
if I changed the
lattice constant to 10
and then simulated?
What's going to happen then?
That was pretty fast.
And look at that.
Now they're far apart.
They sort of look like--
let's see.
There's the band structure.
Ooh!
I love that reaction there.
That was-- that had
some meaning in it.
Whoever that was, thank you,
because I felt a connection.
What just happened?
What is this?
What are these?
AUDIENCE: Energy bands.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Energy bands.
They are still energy bands--
varying k-space.
But they don't vary in k-space.
But you-- doesn't mean
you can't compute them
at different k-points,
which the code did.
But they're flat, which
means they're not really
interacting in any sort
of periodic way anymore.
They're so far apart that
the periodic potentials
don't really overlap.
They don't feel each other.
So what do I have left then?
What is it?
What am I staring at?
AUDIENCE: Silicon.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Silicon atom.
That's all that--
those are the states.
That's-- which state is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
But which state is that?
AUDIENCE: 4s?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: It would
be if we had all the electrons.
So it is a little tough.
But we only have the outer four.
So it's actually the 3s.
3s, 3p-- our friend,
silicon atom, is back.
We went from atoms to
molecules to solids.
And now we just did an atom.
And you see, as I
bring those atoms,
as I-- so those are the
atomic levels of silicon.
They don't vary in k-space.
A molecule of silicon
wouldn't vary in k-space.
But as I start to
make this thing feel
a "repeatiness," then
Bloch's theorem kicks in
and energies depend on k.
And that changes the
properties of the material.
So that's all really important.
Now, one more thing while
we have the tool up--
well, so now we're
actually-- we're
pretty well-equipped to
try a whole bunch of stuff.
And we're going to
understand what we're doing.
Let me just ask
you one more thing.
If I look at these inputs--
let's pull up
alpha-quartz, let's say.
There's alpha-quartz.
Now, if I look at these
inputs, what else might
you want to think
about converging?
We talked about the
k-point mesh, something
not as bad as alpha-quartz.
Aluminum-- well,
that's nice, one atom.
What else besides
the k-point mesh,
and you better use more
k-points than one for aluminum--
besides that, what else might--
ooh, I just pointed to it--
might I want to converge
or make sure is right--
the lattice constant.
You see, I'm just giving this
to you because it's there.
Where did it come from?
Is it the right lattice
constant for this choice
of theory and basis set?
Is it the right one?
Well, you should make sure there
are no forces in the system.
You should relax your system.
And that gets to the
point I want to make.
How do you relax a
solid, because there's
now two things, not one,
that you need to care about?
Tell me what the two things are.
Well, how do you
relax a molecule?
When you say optimize
structure, what's it doing?
AUDIENCE: Minimizing
free energy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
By doing what?
What's it calculating?
AUDIENCE: Energy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Which is also called what?
AUDIENCE: Force.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
The force on each atom.
And it pushes them
along the force
until they get to some minimum.
Now, when I have a
solid, I have two things.
I have the force on each
atom, same as the molecule,
the force on each atom in
the basis, as well as what?
AUDIENCE: Volume.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: The volume,
which is set by the what?
AUDIENCE: Lattice constant.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: By
the lattice constant.
So you need to
converge both of those.
And, well, in aluminum, there's
only one atom in the basis
because, you see,
aluminum is an FCC metal.
So all I need is one atom in
the corner of an FCC unit cell.
And I can simulate it.
But there is the
lattice constant
that I need to play with.
Now, if I had a
more complex solid,
like alpha-quartz, which has a
number of atoms in the basis,
then the relative positions of
those atoms may be important.
And you may need to relax that.
You may not.
But it's something you
need to be aware of.
And you can go in.
And you can look at the
forces on these materials.
And you definitely have
to know whether you're
at the minimum in terms
of the lattice constant.
So let's do aluminum
just because it's here.
We'll do four k-points, which is
not enough to look at a metal.
But we'll do it because
it should be fairly fast.
There's the energy.
And-- oh, look at that.
Isn't that beautiful?
It knew to change the
color and everything--
very smart, smart tool.
And here we go back.
And tell me--
somebody tell me what
they think the band
structure is going
to look like for aluminum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Is it going to be what?
Flat?
AUDIENCE: Curved.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Curved.
How many say curved?
How many say flat?
Good.
Look at that.
That's curved.
That's seriously curved.
And if we include-- if we
looked at different energies,
we'd see even more
spaghetti, lots of curvy--
Oh, and look at this.
Oh, let's get the DoS.
This is so exciting.
I forgot about the DoS.
There's the DoS near
the Fermi energy.
Fermi energy is right here.
Is there a gap in this material?
No.
Should there have been?
No because,
remember, in a metal,
you've got states coming
in all over the place
from below the Fermi energy and
above-- continues across it.
That's what tells
you it's a metal.
Now, is alpha-quartz-- let's--
that's a nice material.
Mostly, I want to
simulate it because I
think it'll be pretty-looking.
And there it is.
Now, is alpha-quartz-- I'm
going to go down to 2 by 2.
Is alpha-quartz a metal or a
semiconductor, or what is it?
AUDIENCE: Insulator?
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Insulator?
Yeah.
What's one clue to the fact
that it's an insulator?
What is that?
AUDIENCE: The inflection
in your voice.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
I'm that easy to read?
Man, I got to work on that.
Is it an insulator or a metal?
I'll try.
Well, besides the
inflection in my voice,
what else could give you a clue?
Well, look at it.
Is it a transparent material?
Well, you can't tell there.
Ooh, it is pretty.
Look at this.
Isn't that cool?
See, this is a periodically
repeating structure.
But the basis has
nine atoms in it.
It's a more complex structure.
And let's look.
Now, it's an insulator.
I'm going to totally
agree with that.
You see right through it.
So you know it's not what?
Absorbing in the
visible, at least.
But since it's an insulator
and it has a large band gap,
even though it's
a solid, what do
you think the bands are going
to look like, curvy or not
so curvy?
AUDIENCE: Not so curvy.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN:
Not as curvy.
They're not usually as curvy.
So here's the DoS.
Look at that beautiful band gap.
This is a band gap
only a mother could--
a father or mother--
that's the beautiful--
and look at this.
There's the band structure.
And you can see that--
look at all those bands.
Look at all those levels.
And they do curve.
They do curve.
But they're not as crazy--
well, they are kind
of spaghetti-like.
But they're not spaghetti-like
near the Fermi energy
or near the gap.
So you look at that.
And you're like,
insulator, first of all,
just because of
how big the gap is.
And then what
we're going to do--
and I still have just
10 minutes for today.
But on Thursday, what
we're going to do
is we're going to show
how, when you look at this,
you can say, not a very
good conductor, certainly
not a good hole conductor.
This is where the
holes would move.
electrons would
move because we're going
to get to that a little bit
on Thursday.
Band structure is so
rich with information.
It's a beautiful thing.
It's emotional.
And if any of you are
feeling that, it's OK.
I'm touching the mic again.
Sorry.
It's OK.
We're good.
Check that.
Roger.
So we're simulating solids.
You understand about
band structures.
We've talked about silicon
and occupied, unoccupied--
you can get the densities,
just like you can in molecules.
And as I said, you
can calculate the--
you what?
You need to find the
equilibrium lattice constant.
And so if you just
do the calculation
at different lattice
constants, you'll
get a variation in energy.
That's what will happen.
And you'll get a minimum.
And that'll be the
lattice constant
that you should run at
for your simulations.
And that's pretty important.
But if you had that
curve already, well,
then you've also got the bulk
modulus, which is pretty cool.
Now, I think that you
probably did this calculation
using classical potentials.
Is that right?
You calculated the bulk modulus?
So this isn't any different.
It's just the-- did you do--
you did periodically
repeating structures,
right, using classical
force fields?
I'm seeing a whole
lot of "I'm not sure."
Yeah?
It's a very "I'm not
sure" kind of moment.
It's OK.
Is it-- did you look at solid
materials in your homeworks?
It's still no, not so sure.
Silicon?
Carbon?
Not so much.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] proteins.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Proteins?
So proteins are a bit
more complex of a beast,
by the way, which you
can't really do using--
you can do parts of proteins
using quantum mechanics.
But it's just too hard.
It's too big.
You can't do that many atoms
to do most full-sized proteins.
So that's a great problem to
study with classical models.
For crystals, like
the two-atom silicon,
eight electrons-- are
all those crystals
in there-- and not to
say 1,000 electrons.
You can do things like calculate
the change in the lattice
with--
change in energy
with the lattice.
And from that-- well,
this is the volume.
But that's just the same as
the change in the lattice.
And from that second
derivative, you
can get the bulk modulus, which
is a very important property.
And this is something
I just went through.
This was that slide
that I talked about.
But it was-- really should have
been an internal discussion.
And where you find the
converged ground state density
and potential with some
k-point mesh that you gave it--
that's what you input--
is the k-points that go
into that calculation.
And then for that, you calculate
the energies at k-points
along all the lines.
And some software-- well,
step 3 is not really a step.
But use some
software to plot it.
And you can download the data
for this from the nanoHUB.
There's a-- I've
been showing you
the version of the plot that
gives you the Greek characters,
which is an image.
But there's another version
that gives you the raw data.
It just doesn't put
the characters on it.
But that will allow you to
compare one run to another
and download the raw data.
And then calculating the DoS
is also a two-step process.
You converge the ground
state density potential.
And then you use that potential
to calculate the energies.
And usually, you want to
do this at a dense k-mesh
because the subtle variations--
see, in a molecule, oftentimes,
the DoS is pretty clear.
If I turn-- well, I guess
I could've just done this.
If I turn, say, an atom
or a molecule on its side,
then I have this.
And you use some kind
of smearing function.
And so your-- well, that
was a bad centering.
And so your DoS
would look like that.
But there'd be
bigger peaks where
you have lots of states
and smaller peaks
where you don't have many.
But, you see, now, I'm
turning a band structure,
and you saw alpha-quartz--
so now I'm turning--
see if I can just show
it one more time--
oh, man.
Seriously?
Oh, it was in another--
I'm turning this
on its side now.
And that's not as easy.
That's trickier.
So there's different
weights of a band
at different parts in energy.
And when I turn this on this
side, you can get DoS shapes,
Density of States, that
are-- that have a--
more features in them.
And to get all those
features just right,
you need to use a dense
k-point mesh, which
is what the code does.
This can be measured.
The DoS can be measured
experimentally--
can use STM to actually
directly measure the DoS.
And we talked
about this already.
You fill up your electrons
to the Fermi level.
If there's any bands
crossing, it's a metal.
If not, it's an insulator
or a semiconductor.
If you have an odd number of
electrons in the unit cell,
it has to be a metal
because the Fermi level is
going to come in in the middle.
Each band takes two electrons.
So if you fill up
to the Fermi level
and the Fermi level is
in the middle of a band,
by definition, it's a metal--
sodium.
And then here is a
picture of diamond.
And the thing that I
want to, again, emphasize
is that from DFT, these
characters of these wiggles
and of these features
are pretty darn good,
but this distance is not.
And so what we-- what we're
going to do in this class,
and we're going to
be proud about it,
is we're going to just
shift these bands up
by a rigid amount
to fix the gap.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: That
was probably electronvolts.
Yeah, it says it
here, electronvolts.
And here, it looks like--
what do we have, like,
a 3-eV gap from DFT?
And so that's about half.
Very often, DFT gives you
a gap that's about half
of the experimental gap,
very often, not at--
always, but very often.
For germanium, it makes it
a semimetal, which it's not.
Does anybody know
what a semimetal is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Not quite.
Here's an indirect band gap.
A semimetal is a cool material.
Germanium is not a
semimetal, but DFT
will tell you it is
because of the gap problem.
Here's an indirect
band gap material.
Which one is it?
AUDIENCE: Silicon.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Sure.
Why not?
And if it's silicon, this
will be 1.1 eV in experiment
and about 0.6 eV in DFT.
And that's the band gap error.
But again, you can shift it.
And that's what
we're going to do.
We're going to be OK with that.
In-- if you switch to germanium,
experiment says it's about
a 0.6- or 0.7-eV gap,
something around there.
But DFT-- that's silicon.
But DFT will put it here.
It'll put this
conduction band below.
It has to actually--
it's-- why didn't
I draw that right?
It's actually-- comes below.
So that is a semimetal
when you have,
basically, its crossings
across the Fermi level,
but in an indirect--
from indirect states.
That's called a semimetal.
And DFT will tell you germanium
is that, which is not--
but you can still shift all
those states up, which we do.
Oh, there's a metal.
Oh, look at that, spaghetti.
You now know-- oh,
and there it is.
See, often in papers, you'll
see in the literature--
so you're now becoming
sort of experts
at seeing a band structure and
seeing it, really seeing it.
And it's a powerful thing.
And there it is with
the DoS next to it,
you see, because that's
just this on the side, which
is why you then plot
the DoS sideways, often,
except that doesn't
quite look right.
But anyway-- oh, maybe this--
yeah.
That's what it should be.
And then we've
talked about this.
And we're going to
talk about this.
We're going to come back
to this a little bit
when we talk about solar cells.
But I have mentioned
this a bunch.
Certainly, this would be a
good third homework set--
is to think about this indirect
versus direct band gap problem.
Somebody tell me, again,
why silicon solar cells
are expensive just so I
can go home today and feel
really good or really bad
because it's bad news?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] bandgap.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah.
But why is that-- why does
that make silicon solar cells
expensive?
AUDIENCE: You have
to make them thick.
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Why do
you have to make them thick?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C. GROSSMAN: Yeah,
because you've got to get--
you see, you got to get--
I think I had it shown here.
Yeah.
See, that's easy
for a photon to do.
I talked about this.
Now, here it is in the cartoon.
That's easy for a photon to do.
That's easy for a photon to do
at different places in energy.
And this would be
absorbing light.
These blue arrows
would be the light
that come from the
solar flux that you're
downloading in your homework.
That's where these
blue arrows come.
And it's easy for those
blue arrows to do this.
But to see-- the thing that
matters is this minimum amount
of energy, the band gap of the
material that is the lowest
amount of energy that it would
take to get an electron up
from the valence into
the conduction bands.
And that, in this
case, is not vertical.
It's not vertical.
It's an indirect gap.
Did I have it there?
And because of that, it's not
very good at absorbing light.
Those photons,
those blue lines--
let's get them back here.
Those blue lines--
they need help.
They can do this.
But they can't do this.
And to do this, you need help.
So you need some kind of kick.
And that means it's a much
less efficient process.
And absorbing light in that
whole region of the spectrum
where a photon would need to
do this-- that whole region
is very inefficient.
And yet that's where the sun is.
That's where the sun is.
And so you've got to
make them really thick.
It's inefficient, but not zero.
So you make them really thick.
So you get that
region of the sun.
But to make them
really thick, you see,
you're generating
electrons and holes.
And those-- that generation
of electrons and holes-- well,
that-- then you've
got to get them out.
You can't just let
them stay there.
And to get them out, well,
you need a good material.
And if they have to go
a long ways to get out,
which they do because you have
to make it so thick because it
doesn't absorb light well
because of the band structure,
then--
where was I, again?
No.
Then you need it to be
a really pure material.
That costs money.
Otherwise, they'll run into
traps and other things.
So what we're going
to do is, on Thursday,
we'll talk a little bit more
about some other properties.
We'll talk about
magnetism, very briefly
show you that you can
do molecular dynamics,
a couple other things.
And then we'll start turning
our attention to solar cells.